your Majesties distinguished members of
the Norwegian Nobel Committee
excellencies ladies and gentlemen it is
with profound humility that I accept
this price on behalf of the organization
for the prohibition of chemical weapons
its member states the ambassadors and
secretary stuff past and present some of
whom are with us today including my
immediate predecessor ambassador
behavior filter this award recognizes
our combined efforts efforts which flow
from the collective spirit of the OPCW
in working towards a common good that
serves all humanity I feel deeply
privileged to be able to address you on
this occasion I also take this
opportunity to honor the memory of
Nelson Mandela it will remain for all of
us and future generations a beacon for
what can be achieved against
overwhelming odds to advance peace
dignity and reconciliation the Nobel
Committee has a long history of honoring
achievement in disarmament yet this is
the first time that the Peace Prize has
been awarded to an organization that is
actively engaged in disarmament as a
practical and ongoing reality for 16
years now the OPCW has been overseeing
the elimination of an entire category of
weapons of mass destruction our task is
to consign chemical weapons to history
forever a task we have been carrying out
with quite determination and no small
measure of success under the terms of
the Chemical Weapons Convention the ox w
has so far verified the destruction of
more than eighty percent of all declared
chemical weapons we have also
implemented a wide range of measures to
prevent such weapons
re-emerging and with 190 states now
members of this global band we are
hastening the vision of a world free of
chemical weapons to reality the
remarkable success of chemical
disarmament has borne out the promise
made by nobel peace prize laureate and
former UN Secretary General Kofi Annan
when he characterized the first meeting
of member states back in 1997 with the
following words it is not merely a great
step in the cause of disarmament and
non-proliferation it is not merely a
signal of restraint and discipline in
war it is much more it's the momentous
act of peace excellencies ladies and
gentlemen there can be no doubt about
the value of this work for chemical
weapons have been used with brutal
regularity over the 20th century and
tragically in this century as well no
weapon of course has a monopoly on
cruelty or little V but chemical weapons
have by any measure and especially
nefarious legacy almost 100 years since
their first large scale used on the
battlefields of Flanders it is worth
reminding ourselves of the reasons why
these weapons invoke such horror right
up to our own time chemical weapons
still the deep-rooted and pathological
fear all humans share of being poisoned
they do not discriminate between
combated and civilian nor between
battlefield and village you cannot see
them you cannot smell them and they
offered no warning for the unsuspecting
but their effects are devastating
burning lining or suffocating their
victims that Israeli instant and never
pains and when they fail to kill as they
often do these weapons inflict lasting
damage on people and their environment
denying them the opportunity to repair
and rebuild in the wake of conflict I
need not describe
these effects in all their gruesome
variations they would defy any
description it's enough to look at the
pictures of victims to understand the
agony that they must have gone through
from Ypres in Belgium to sir dash in
Iran from Halabja Iraq to goethe in
syria and we only need to look at the
fate of the survivors of such attacks
people destined to spend the rest of
their lives suffering unbearable
physical or psychological pain to
understand why such weapons must be
banned chemical weapons evolved over
time with the discovery of new and
deadly rages but whatever their form
they share one common purpose to invoke
fear and Submission through the
horrifying nature of their impact scores
of victims beyond the battlefield have
attested to this in accepting this price
on behalf of the OPCW I also pay homage
to all these victims the first attempt
to bend the use of chemical weapons
under international law was the heck
Hague Convention of eighteen ninety nine
the fact that this treaty was not
observed during the First World War
prompted immediate efforts to negotiate
a stronger known these efforts resulted
in the 1925 Geneva Protocol while it's
prohibited the use of chemical weapons
the protocol did not bend their
production or possession history Alice
did not bear out its robustness chemical
weapons continued to be used across the
globe including against civilian
populations and alarmingly large and
more sophisticated Arsenal's were
developed during the Cold War it was not
until the 1980s that negotiations for a
more comprehensive chemical weapons
treaty get underway in earnest chemical
attacks being perpetrated at that time
by the former regime in Iraq added to
the urgency of this process fortunately
it was not only the brutal effects of
chemical
that focused minds what drove the
negotiators was also the imperative to
ensure the effectiveness of the future
not to bend these weapons states were
adamant that chemical weapons had to be
made a thing of the past by deeds not
just words what they straw for was a
treaty that all but enforce compliance
coming closer than any predecessor to
guaranteeing adherence to its provisions
and after almost two decades of
difficult negotiations they succeeded
their efforts gave birth to the full
global ban that came to be known as the
Chemical Weapons Convention and to an
entirely independent organization the
OPCW to oversee its implementation as
difficult as the challenges in bilateral
arms control have been concluding this
multilateral treaty was clearly a
singular achievement it also stands as a
major tribe in the history of
multilateralism almost 80 years after
the first life scale use of chemical
weapons the collective determination of
states was finally able to shine through
in comprehensively bending his weapons
this result of the community of nations
lays testimony to the very best that can
be achieved by multilateralism in the
cause of peace and security as Benjamin
Disraeli observed through perseverance
many people win success out of what
seemed destined to be certain failure I
pay tribute here to all those who
through their dedication and resolve
contributed to this hard-won success for
chemical disarmament and I commend
governments for their courage and
foresight in taking this bold step it
was out of these negotiations that the
crucible of the unique success of the
Chemical Weapons Convention was forged a
comprehensive international verification
mechanism a mechanism that had no prior
model and had to be developed from
scratch a mechanism that obliges every
one of the
mentions 190 member states without
discrimination to destroy its chemical
weapons talks and production facilities
and to lay bare tree inspection and
industrial facilities that could be used
for purposes prohibited by this treaty a
mechanism that Brooks Brooks no
exceptions and can conduct inspections
as short notice to investigate alleged
use of chemical weapons or suspicions
over band activities in short a
mechanism that places the onus on States
to ensure full transparency with IV
their obligations with the OPCW acting
as arbiter and guardian of the chemical
weapons convention with the entry into
force of the convention in 1997 we have
thus been able to cross and link the
white space in disarmament between
passion and practicality between
sentiment and action between noble
ambition and concrete achievements and
for the first time in the history of
multilateral diplomacy we were able to
show that consensus based decision
making can yield practical effective an
avowal verifiable results in disarmament
from where we stand now I commend Member
States commitment to effective
implementation of the Commission the
conventions achievements make the recent
chemical attacks in Syria which shocks
that shocked us all even more tragic for
they highlight the manifest security
advantages that stays adhering to the
convention enjoy in the 16 years that
the convention has been enforced no
member state as experienced an attack
with chemical weapons thankfully the
international response to those attacks
set in motion and extraordinary series
of events these resulted in Syria's
accession to the convention and
frontline Rove for the OPCW working
together with the United Nations to
eliminate Syrian chemical weapons never
in its history has the ops w overseen
the distraction of such a major chemical
weapons stockpile in the midst of a
civil war and in such compressed time
frames
but as much as this mission is testing
our capacities and resources our
progress so far has only strengthened
our confidence that we can succeed I'm
immensely proud of those staff members
from the obstacle you as well as the UN
we have volunteered to work in Syria in
what are extremely challenging
circumstances their dedication and
personal courage do a great credit to
both organizations
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
international consensus on the
elimination of Syria's chemical weapons
has as its basis the same consensus that
drove the Chemical Weapons Convention
conclusion the challenge now is to / she
ate those six countries still outside
the convention to join it without delay
or conditions there has long been no
reasonable defense for not doing so all
the more now in the wake of the robust
international reaction to recent use of
chemical weapons non-asian interest can
credibly outweigh either the security or
economic benefits of adhering to the
global ban of chemical weapons it's my
fervent hope that this award will spur
on efforts to make the Chemical Weapons
Convention a truly universal norm
Universal adherence to the convention
would be the most enduring investment in
its integrity and the best guarantee of
three we cannot allow the tragedy that
befell the people of Goethe to be
repeated the durability of the chemical
weapons convention halls as much to what
followed in the implementation of the
treaty as to what was negotiated into it
key in this regard are the opcw's active
partnerships with science these
partnerships have in significant measure
defined the success of the convention
because of the dual use nature of what
goes into making chemical weapons many
of their materials and technologies also
have beneficial commercial and
industrial applications without a common
understanding of where the line must be
drawn between what helps us and what
harms us there can be no effective
verification it is the opcw's
partnerships with science that have
drawn this line in a clear and
defensible way they have done so by
devising tools and methods for defining
detecting and protecting against
chemical chemical weapon agents and
monitoring new and emerging technologies
of potential concern more than this they
have facilitated the sharing of such
information
between peers and crucially they have
opened up a new sort of dialogue that
makes the impact of scientific
discoveries better understood we need to
deal with the situation in which as
Isaac Asimov put it science gathers
knowledge faster than society gathers
wisdom it is for this reason that the
OPCW has worked hard to enhance
awareness of the often fine line between
beneficial and harmful applications in
chemistry through education programs and
outreach to academia our aim is to
contribute to efforts towards fostering
a culture of responsible science
this will ensure that current and future
generations of scientists understand and
respect the impact that their work can
have on security what we are striving to
create together with our partners is a
two tiered structure for supporting
advances in chemistry one that
accommodates a collective early warning
system for scientific discoveries that
could be misused and a global repository
for knowledge expertise and technologies
that should benefit all nations industry
has been no less important partner for
the achievement of course enshrined in
the Chemical Weapons Convention its
concerns were discussed and addressed
from the very beginning of the
negotiations on the Commission
specifically industry had to have
complete confidence in arrangements made
for commercial protection without such
arrangements there could be no
productive collaboration and therefore
no access to commercial chemical
facilities for inspections even the
degree to which the conventions
verification requirements are entangled
with normal commercial and industrial
processes industry's active
participation is vital some 2,500 500
inspections later in more than 80
countries we have shown that the
conventions Arrangements work our
ambition now is to better integrate
industry as a partner working to ensure
continued and effective implementation
of the Commission more broadly this sort
of partnership with the private sector
points a way forward for many of the
non-traditional multilateral challenges
we are facing from climate change to
poverty alleviation it's a key array of
focus for the opcw's efforts to augment
the conventions profile and adherence to
it when the Chemical Weapons Convention
was concluded in 1992 it was rightly
heralded as the most tangible
disarmament outcome of the immediate
post Cold War period but over the more
than two decades since then we have
little else to show in the area of
discernment for the enormous peace
dividend that the end of the Cold War
brought us
it's high time to move towards a
different more durable security in
keeping with the extraordinary
opportunities that globalization has
brought a security that accommodates
human development economic cooperation
and mutual prosperity effective
effective implementation of the chemical
weapons convention has played a
definitive role in empowering a broader
community of stakeholders to this end
their voices are persuasive because they
are pragmatic they issue moral argument
in favor of facts and their modes of
presentation only enhance their
credibility these include objective
assessments of verification methods
innovative cost-benefit analysis of
retaining weapons of mass destruction
and Frank reviews of the commercial
impact of treaty compliance finally they
have been able to give expression to
their voices and test their judgements
through new habits of dialogue and
cooperation between scientists and
policymakers between industry and
academia and between civil society and
government officials it is these sorts
of habits that the opposite of you is
committed to fostering as a means of
preserving the legacy of the 2013 Nobel
Peace Prize I announced here that the
prize money awarded by the Nobel
Committee will be used to fund annual
orchestra awards these awards will
recognize outstanding contributions to
advancing the goals of the convention I
am sure that along with other
stakeholders the civil society will
continue to play a significant role in
this regard for its part the ops w will
do its utmost to remain a highly
effective organization an organization
that continues to invest in its most
valuable asset a cadre of highly skilled
and dedicated people an organization
that anticipates future challenges and
an organization that adapts its
resources and expertise to be able to
respond to them Syria has tested us in
this regard verifying the declaration of
a member state is a routine activity for
the ops w but there is clearly nothing
routine about the circumstances in which
we are doing so in that country we would
welcome the opportunity of new member
states submitting themselves to the
verification regime of the Commission at
the same time we are looking beyond what
we do to how we do it our aim is to
build on our 16 year record of success
by increasing our efficiency and
broadening our reach this not only means
staying abreast of scientific and
technological advances that may test our
understanding of what constitutes a
chemical weapon it also requires us to
ensure that we are making the best
possible use of advances in
communication especially publicly
available tools having seen how rapidly
information can be conveyed by social
media and critically verified through
images we need to consider how we might
harm such tools for our monitoring
verification and investigation
activities this could render particular
benefits for our work with member states
to prevent non-state actors from gaining
access to dual use materials and
know-how and in our world of globalized
trade and supply chains it could
potentially help members days further
improve their ability to track exports
of dual-use goods and materials to
ensure that these Goods go where they
are supposed to go and are used for
purposes they are intended to be used
for we are also thinking about how we
can employ new communication tools to
raise awareness of the need to practice
responsible science to instill the
highest ethical standards in our future
scientists and researchers finally we
are expanding and deepening our
interaction with other international
organizations the United Nations is
central in this regard whether in
partnership on the ground in Syria or in
our broader mutually reinforcing efforts
to promote disarmament we are likewise
engaging regional organizations to use
their forums and networks for raising
awareness of the goals of the chemical
weapons convention including in helping
secure universality our interaction with
other specialised international agencies
is usefully at identifying areas of
overlap that enhanced chemical security
ranging from addressing transnational
crime and terrorism to building capacity
for chemical emergency responses and we
are working with others arms control
treaty organizations to exchange best
practices in areas ranging from julius
challenges to verification method
institutional cooperation is the bedrock
of the broader stakeholder engagement on
which the obstacle prides itself
cooperation which I hope we can
underwrite with increased communication
and social networking stimulating fresh
ideas and innovative inputs your
Majesty's distinguished members of
Norwegian Nobel Committee excellencies
ladies and gentlemen the Easter of arms
control has shown no lack of passion yet
when so much is at stake patient must
take care to grant to grant itself in
reality if it is to achieve its
ambitions this means being pragmatic
clear minded even dispassionate about
acquiring the best possible tools for
achieving and consolidating disarmament
goals and it often means government
roving the political courage to take
tough decisions for the benefit of the
community of nations the chemical
weapons convention has shown that the
sort of an approach yields a result
results for the convention is more than
mere words and promises on a piece of
paper it is a comprehensive regime
geared towards reading the word of
chemical weapons and making sure they
never again threaten human kind in this
regime member states provide the world
behind the Commission and it is the OPCW
that provides the force for making its
goals a reality our work imbued with
resolve and certitude is the
international community's guarantee of
the Commission's implementation it shows
that from lofty dreams we can carve out
steps leading us from vision reality it
took almost a century to achieve a total
ban on chemical weapons essentially over
which thousands fell victim to these
heinous weapons a century eight thousand
we can now look to a future free of the
scourge they represent no value can be
placed on this achievement and no effort
should be spared in sharing the gains it
has brought us those of us we have
worked towards chemical disarmament
recognized that with our success also
comes in all
negation to broaden it the chemical
weapons convention has given us a legacy
that no future disarmament effort can
afford to ignore a legacy that has at
score verification rod stakeholder
engagement consensus born of trust and
above all a commitment to science that
actively serves the cause of peace and
security it is this legacy that we must
set as the Keystone in an ever widening
arch of disarmament only by building
such an arch will we be able to bridge
our security and our prosperity destiny
has ruled that we read the world of
chemical weapons and that we achieve
this in our lifetime this is our place
in history and this is the future we are
creating a future for which our children
and grandchildren can be truly thankful
I think